si marina et puff
[Musique]
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soit à peine hors de combat seulement
alain chabat a revendu les quatre autres
pour rentrer dans ses frais c'est une
vanne qui laisserait croire que le film
des robes 1re a été un échec
ce qui n'est pas vrai du tout il est
amorti l'état martin a fait 2 millions
d'entrées ça fait quoi alors de faire un
bide à 2 millions d'entrées basque
landes
c'est pas facile de faire un bide à 2
millions d'entrées maintenant ça met la
barre très haute pour les prochains by
dre vous avez vécu ça comme ont
difficilement j'imagine en dépend
j'aurais préféré faire un triomphe à 200
mille entrées tout est bon tiens rien
pour sa mère suisse avant l'aurore moi
j'ai ma première saison j'ai écrit je
t'aime
elle est collector les gens réagissent
comment quand vous leur dites vous avez
fait un bide à 2 millions d'entrées ils
ont de la peine à mes parents ils ont
honte mais disent pas à tant qu'on a la
santé ce pas là
c'est important la santé et la santé
non c'est vrai que de m'y rendre et
c'est pas beaucoup pour les parties
comment remercier les spectateurs à
bahreïn qui restent beaucoup plus de
français environ 58 millions qui n'ont
pas vu c'est ce qu'il faut dit c'est
vrai ouais c'est à peu près le nombre de
gens qui regardent passer l'émission de
samedi m'insurger il y en a 2 millions à
peu près qui la regarde oui qu'est ce
qu'ils font c'est ce que je me dis
toujours c'est moi où tu dis ça parce
que je suis qu'est-ce qu'ils font le
samedi soir des gens alors votre
objectif c'est quoi maintenant habib à
4030 régime agira 1 ouais vous êtes
parti ça y est vous êtes vous travaillé
dessus déjà posé on y est c'est oui ça
c'est du tout petit étape de travail on
s'achète des stylos oui alors le dvd que
vous venez promotionner ce soir ça peut
être quoi un bide amis en os ça serait
bien non alors le meilleur moyen pour
pour pour que ça marche c'est pas trop
en parler
on espère oui qu'est-ce que j'ai eus
crise
qu'est ce qu'il est non c'est la non oui
oui maintenant difficile de passer sous
silence les guest en plus des robins il
ya bahia farrugia l écart hamdi elie
semoun edouard baer avec un bonus
macha béranger oui macha béranger aussi
d'autres à venir et de travail elle dit
sinon il ya le backstage de la coulisse
la leçon de cinéma de télé et le visage
de la voie du générique
voilà ça si les bonus cd bonus alors
comment faire pour a montré un extrait
maintenant voici comment on peut faire
il suffit de pas dire magnéto serge
klein ne dit pas magnéto serge pendant
les jeux
pourquoi tu as pris la mayonnaise
souffert le sens parce que j'ai plein de
bulles que shop vous êtes italiens 6 mai
alors vous parler l'italien si ma mamie
à spaghetti 1001 ce qu'est ce que vous
conseiller d'aller sting et j'ajoute que
je porte plainte contre x
c'est quoi une plainte contre x et une
plaine pornographiques merde merde temps
collé nom ne soit reçue par le cardinal
pas s'il fallait dire dans tes mains
parce qu'elle nous a quittés je me
souviens encore de lui ce matin me
disant j'aime la vie
oui mais la vie ne t'aimais pas pascal
j'avais bu du champomy et j'étais bourré
à banon c'est ce jour là c'est moi qui
me suis fait bourrer non non non mais là
autant de vulgarité moi ça me transperce
l'anus un méchant mais jamais seul
tu voulais me donne aux mille écus j'ai
pu de quoi j'ai pu moi-même recul
et on m'avait voilà cape et l'épée tome
qu'est ce qu'on peut bien de plus pas
que si on vit ici on en parle un petit
peu on va encore à vendre un million ce
serait ridicule
oui on serait ça serait con non toute
façon nous on n'a rien à dire on est
trop nul en promo donc non c'est pas
vrai c'est à dire qu'on aime tellement
ce qu'on fait oui on est trop proche
ça ne veut rien dire ça non plus c'est à
dire qu'on aime tellement ce qu'on fait
et drôle
d'accord je joue toujours non c'est à
dire que on aime tellement ce qu'on fait
dans les robins que on a du mal à en
parler c'est comme si on doit parler de
notre enfant voilà on en a pas en plus
oui marine elle est drôle c'est la femme
drôle au bois tu fais du tennis toi non
ah bon c'est dommage je lui en avais un
joueur je fais d'équitation mais ça
tombe bien on a un cheval c'est pas
sympa pour un mandat
voir les gens ils le sentent dans ces
limites ne sont pas dupes
[Musique]
attention si vous étiez un défaut marina
vous seriez quoi la radinerie way et toi
tu cette marina vous venger de ce que
vous avez dit que vous étiez une injure
zut
va te faire cuire le q si vous étiez une
maladie je serai un toc troubles
obsessionnels le travail salon j'écris
la turquie une pièce qui sera produite à
bientôt
les prochaines et alors que nous la
meilleure vannes pour voir ça commence
c'est demain qu'il y ait pour du rapliq
c'est allez tous vous faire [ __ ]
c'est bien je tâtonne ces jeunes n'ont
melville a le syndrome gilles de la
tourette donc c'est normal qu'ils disent
si vous étiez une maladie ou un petit
rhume mais avec plein de morgue
voilà c'est exactement ce que j'allais
bien si vous étiez un accident alors moi
je serais un accident très idiot qui est
arrivé pour de vrai à la mère d'un ami
elle s'est auto écrasé avec sa voiture
c'est à dire qu'elle était dans un
parking de son parking lac était en
pente et elle a oublié le frein à main
est sorti pour prendre un truc et paf le
pied s'est coincé et attendait c'était
très grave parce qu'on a dû lui ôter les
deux poumons tout nord je dois dire
mairie 20 si vous étiez une perversion
marina est vieillot fini si vous étiez
une perversion je serais ce que vous
m'avez proposé de faire en coulisses
tout arriver si vous étiez indice une
boulons
[Rires]
c'est bien fait c'est une trahison aller
chez fogiel aa
[Applaudissements]
ils trahison je balance risque que vous
m'avez proposé de faire un colis si vous
étiez un poison à la cigarette j'aime
trop c'est bien bien la preuve au renvoi
la nicotine bravo moi j'y serai un
poisson rouge
si vous étiez pas beaucoup oh lola
non mais oh ça va on a droit d'être très
grossier ce band et moi je demande tout
le temps oh la la
moi je serais une panne d'électricité
pendant la finale de la coupe du monde
ça voilà voilà
tu l'as randy avaient alors moi aussi
parce qu'elle presque j'ai rajouté
allez-vous macarons sous la pluie depuis
un moment à l'interné depuis troyes
vannes
si vous étiez une infirmité élise
larnicol de redonner voix vous étiez
hamas à quelqu'un qui ferait un crime
parfait
d'ailleurs je sais ce que c'est que le
crime parfait j'ai réfléchi c'est un
crime gratuit
parce que si c'est un acte gratuit c'est
impossible on se retrouve
bah ouais alors ce soir marina a donné
des bons conseils fumée crime gratuit
parfait si vous étiez une mort pas
définitive si vous étiez un microbe un
microbe de ahmed 80
[Rires]
merci serge même si tu trouves que je
suis mal habillé merci quoi il a dit que
c'était ma baby d'habitude et le public
ne sait pas que serge khalfon s'habille
exclusivement en prada donc forcément ça
tu vois un tee shirt il a des sénateurs
le mieux habillé de paris-sorbonne qu'un
réalisateur mannequin slovaque
d'intermec absolument jeté deux bâches
géantes renault tu m'as serge tout le
monde le sait en tentant pas n'est pas
d'échangé dont il le chante si marina
foïs et f
elle était là
ouais
si nous faire mourir marina était voilà
vous connaissez à la
à la banque le petit protégé de le petit
protégé de pascal sevran
pascal voulez mais parce qu'elle sevran
pef à mais je connais pas bien mais je
vois j'aime bien le personnage parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui dit ce qu'il pense
voilà donc j'aime bien les gens qui
disent qu'ils pensent pouvoir connu que
le second ordinaire à l'envi d'être ici
ce soir pour vous êtes ici ce soir
vous êtes ici ce soir pour un livre
signé par les robins des bois qui
s'appelle l'histoire de france 2 avant a
maintenant chez canal+ édition marina
est une des seules femmes enceintes
alcoolique
ça sera ça
à
[Musique]
j'envoie
c'est la chanteuse préférée après janis
joplin
je ne pense pas qu'il sert de faire
l'apologie l'apologie du de l'alcoolisme
pour construire dans la chaussée en fait
là c'était bruno gaccio
dis moi c'est le seul moyen que tu as
trouvé pour avoir de grosse casse est
tombée enceinte
oui alors bon puisqu'on parle de mes
seins tout de suite gens très contente
c'est même pas tellement vrai si vous
voulez la vérité ils ont pas tellement
grossi c'était très simple vous avez
touché pêche pour nom mais je peux
toucher bas mais le rsa peut être
vulgaire mais comme c'est une vieille
amie et ben c'est dur à dire que moi n'y
en a plus c'est dur c'est normal avec
vos évènements tu as des jolies
chaussures moi merci alors là c'est les
prés de l'étang comment tu te souviens
encore le prix marina
est-ce que désormais vous vous sentez
plus femme au fond de vous ouais je
crois que rose de mercy le plus beau
jour de ma vie
est ce que le regard des hommes a changé
sur vous marina ouais alors alors je
voudrais annoncer aux filles si vous
comptez vous faire draguer quand vous
êtes enceinte c'est loupé ah bon mais ça
marche plus du tout pas du tout mais dit
faisait draguer quand tu étais enceinte
tu as raison vous avez des sales vous
vous sentez plus proche de refus de
ouais vous pensez que les robins savez
que vous devez avoir un enfant marina
bay je leur ai demandé l'autorisation
bien sûr ainsi qu'un rapport sexuel à
chacun mais je ne sais plus qui a gagné
ah bon on va vite le voir un si petit et
choc
vous pensez qu'il s'en rendrait compte
que vous étiez une femme qui désiraient
avoir un enfant non parce que c'est vrai
qu'ils montrent toujours vu comme un
auteur et f
au nom ainsi attention ça va être sur
tes seins et j'ai déjà l'un des plus
gros que marina ont pu faire donc oui au
sein oui c'est vrai que par rapport à
mes seins si j'ai décidé de pas faire
d'enfant c'était pour qu'ils restent
tels que je sais pas s'il veut dire tel
quel ou tu as eu coup alors j'ai dit ok
diffusant deux
donc vous êtes ici ce soir pour un livre
d'histoires drôles dans un livre dix
noms un livre d'histoire avec un grand h
une histoire de la france dont notre
joli pays aux mille fromages virgule
livre qui est drôle pareil si vous
utilisez très peu de mots un mot prend
comprend pas le sens de ce que vous
dites est ce que voulait bien nous en
détail et du contenu
est ce que vous voulez bien mais en
détail et oui je prenais une inspire
avant de parler c'est normal voilà
écoutez ça s'appelle déjà
l'histoire de france 2 avant a
maintenant c'est un livre assez
exhaustif sur donc tout ce qui s'est
passé dans notre pays depuis qu'il
existe
c'est la ligne éditoriale c'est vraiment
un souci de vérité
en gros tout est vrai à part les faits
et les dates
c'est un livre qui est destiné à toutes
les personnes qui désirent perpétuer
leur ignorance
c'est à dire les robins des bois par
exemple de faire 6 6 livres achetés ça
va à dame
ça va pas mal écoute
adam back sur le port d'amsterdam va
porter amsterdam non je peux pas je peux
pas faire ça c'est sûr parce que je
pense que c'est si atroce parce que j'ai
pas le costume pour chanter amsterdam
aussi il ya des dealers de shit mais moi
j'ai jamais entendue est ce que c'est
vrai marina que alain decaux a voulu
vous casser la gueule après avoir vu que
ouais mais c'est moi qui lui ai pété les
jambes vous suivez à l'année sui ahmed
suis pas là pour faire une interview
alain decaux raconte on se concentre en
tant que spécialiste vous allez nous
répondre louis xiv était il mieux que
louis xiii louis xiv et est divisible ce
qui n'est pas le cas de louis xiii qui
est vrai
oui louis xiii était premier en fait
c'est simple
l'ancien régime et est il efficace non
si un régime c'était à base de popopopop
way témoignages ou habitant le plus de
chance de croiser des gens phrase
aveugle folie trois bonnes réponses
bonne réponse le mari n'a que sa
grossesse n'empêche pas d'avoir de
l'esprit pourquoi at on pris la bastille
le 14 juillet moi ça c'est évident alors
ça on n'a pas eu besoin de potasser pour
le savoir parce que comme c'était un
jour férié le 14 juillet tout le monde
était libre pour pour aller prendre cet
hymne est ce que ça valait le coup de
prendre la bastille bah ouais en même
temps pour remettre l'opéra à la place
c'était pas terrible non c'est pas très
malin
quelle est la particularité du château
de chambourcy
il avoue crème de quoi était inspiré
d'une histoire vraie kse l'instar du
premier crime de l'humanité
mais pareil ça c'est toujours parce que
nous on a une réputation de légèreté
tout mais pareilles erreurs on a fait
une enquête on a retrouvé le premier
criminel de l'humanité on a raconté son
histoire et c'est bien c'est sortir 2 et
bien ouais quand est apparue régime
régine la chanteuse à la renaissance
bravo
nous et il est plus facile de faire un
créneau
bon ça dans un château en château en
château fort chez nous il doit on y voit
là j'ai compris c'est à lui qu'est ce
qui fait toute la journée avec volets je
ne sais pas si c'est parce que m'ouvre
les yeux je suis en train de me dire
qu'il est temps encore une fois de
changer l'équipe mag autant entend faut
le faire il faut spurs obligé c'est toi
qui as tu vas pouvoir de vie et de mort
sur des cartes sim dit dégage par
exemple je dégage là existe-t-il
d'autres types de château les châteaux
faible c'est qu'il les sorte de château
de sable donc c'est pas des gens qui
avaient pas les moyens n'étaient pas
très costaud qu'elle n'est pas la muscu
voilà c'est des châteaux faible mais à
l'homme il est beau grand nom sympa il
est il héritera rigueur là c'est
vraiment petit laban m'écoute je fais
pas mal enfin franchement je pense que
vous avez manqué de respect à pascal 1
mais je reste et je représente c'est
bien qu'ils le successeur de napoléon
c'est serge lama enfin bien que signifie
la quarantaine pour un homme que c'est
bientôt fini
aulas alors pascal d'où vient le nom de
la 4l ben ça vient d'henri iv en fait
bien qu avait également pour les pros
les gens les plus riches avaient créé le
henry henry qui est devenu le 4 4 mai
j'ai dit et ça donne envie d'acheter
que signifie 15 15 ça ça c'est égalité
seomoz tennis voilà très bien c'est
aussi aussi marignan mais c'est
marignane voilà des mois
[Musique]
je suis quand même
si on y va
[Musique]
alors on s'est fait de la mise en scène
j'ai mis en scène les robes à eric et
ramzy kadéos patrick bosso isabelle
nanty et puis un jour sur le tournage de
la tour montparnasse infernale christian
fechner vous dit tu devrais écrire ton
film a déjà commencé à travailler dans
votre dans votre tête mais fait chier
n'aime pas l'idée que le héros reste un
gamin comme ça qu'ils soient
complètement lunaire vous voyez chabat
ensuite vous voyez claude berri qui vous
dit c'est formidable malheureusement
chez pathé ça se passe pas aussi bien et
vous rencontrer laurent pétin et la lui
il aime l'idée il a envie de faire le
film
vous êtes très inquiet parce que vous
dites j'ai été obligé d'abandonner mon
rôle pour pour un jamel debbouze pour un
clovis cornillac que j'adore alors que
vous citez mais c'est vrai que ça me
faisait mal au derrière de données hier
tu vois c'est tout près des zones et mon
personnage a même à un acteur que
j'adore comme djamel ou cornillac parce
que parce que je me l'écrivait c'est ma
vie quoique j'ai mis dedans je
m'attendais à ce qu'on me propose et on
m'a pas proposé de donner mort est
difficile parce que tout le monde a été
à comme un peu échaudé par l'échec de
rue on a fait quand même 1 million 800
mille spectateurs mais comme il y avait
marqué dans toutes les vitrines que
c'était de la merde ah c'est sûr que ça
fait mal après ouais se retrouve un peu
son travail pour certains d'entre nous
et ça m'a permis d'écrire un beau film
et ben voilà vous êtes là ce soir
voilà finalement je ne reviens pas
[Musique]